Senate Democrats are under pressure to
block President Trump's latest cabinet
nominees CIA Chief Mike Pompeo to be the
next Secretary of State and CIA vet Gina
Haskell to lead that agency the
pressures coming from left-wing
activists the exact people we need to
decide who's in charge of national
security I joke asking a lefty for
suggestions on national security is like
asking a conservative for tips on vegan
restaurants it's not our wheelhouse but
first I don't blame them this is what
ideologues do when they're out of power
you play defense sure it's petty to
block nominations but it's when it's all
you got it's all you got Republicans
have done it too but this is different
this is national security when
Republicans block they usually have
stronger alternatives to fill those
spots not wimpier ones if the right
hates your choices for national security
it's because they know national security
so we got asked what is your alternative
Oh concerned activists that won't please
our enemies Chelsea Manning to head the
CIA Bill Ayers for Secretary of State I
exaggerate because it's fun but whatever
a left winger suggests will always be
toothless for national security makes
them wince when you believe that
enhanced interrogation is really mean to
bad people who aren't really bad at all
because they're just victims of
America's oppressive foreign policy you
should probably go away and let the
adults handle this it's a fact
Dana national security that's a
Republican domain Democrats are just set
it out when it's done their votes yeah
it's true
but they just mail into votes that's
what I do I'm here absentee absentee
I've Steve it's like you know I like how
Republicans are terrible with big
government they're terrible with foreign
policy yeah well bad with big government
as soon as they are passing a bill today
that was gonna spend a trillion dollars
an omnibus but it changed for Gina
Hospital this is going to be a tough
confirmation yeah and there were there
were no war crimes though there was
nothing illegal and how do we know that
because if there had been I guarantee
you that former attorney General Eric
Holder would have prosecuted her
others three attorneys general have
looked at this they have not taken any
action and so the problem is Greg there
is no logic or reasoning with people on
this issue yes so the president chose to
have to have a fight on this
confirmation he could have gone with
somebody that you didn't require that
spending a lot of clinical capital and
all the pain and agony is gonna take to
get her confirmed but in a way I wonder
if the president is thinking that he
wants this fight for the point that you
made about national security yeah
Kimberly yeah
blocking nominations that's what you do
when you're out of power right it's like
it's all you don't have much else to do
right yeah that's just like totally lame
I think bush-league moved not president
um you know what if I were Jena [ __ ]
I would ensure that I would get
nominated and that they would approve me
because I would sit there and face all
those men on that thing and say you know
what waterboard me yeah waterboard me
I'll show you it's not so bad you know
and literally just like she stands by
her record what she's done she's
incredibly capable she's very tough
she's smart
and you know she's authentic very
genuine it's not a hypocrite we lucky to
have her I think it's fantastic and I
don't know what the Democrats are gonna
really have to gain by trying to like
block a woman and fight these battles
out they've got midterm elections coming
up some of the projections are not
looking good for your team one
whatsoever and you know I term elections
yeah I think so yes absolutely the kids
might pick up about three seats you wait
and see while you're gonna be crying in
your soup and he does he does like soup
you know one Alton how do you feel about
being I guess connected to such a sexist
party that would reject a woman will be
the first head of CIA I mean should you
be with her why with her Hillary be with
her yes yes yes I you know I think you
were with her when she was destroying
the tapes yeah or maybe maybe you know
you were you and Hillary maybe you were
with an email maybe you can be with her
I think that given the fact that she
needs Democratic votes because of Rand
Paul McCain's not there I think that
they're gonna have to do something like
specifically have her sit there and say
I renounced
the use of torture I understand this is
a matter of conscience for us as
Americans this is not who we are as an
American people and we're not going to
do it great vote counter don't say that
crushing it and putting down the
nomination if you didn't know they were
gonna get some red state Democrats to go
ahead and support her no you could say
that about Pompeo
but I don't think you can say that about
Haspel because I think this is a real
issue of torture and people left and
right who are uncomfortable with it
Jesse it wasn't torture though was
torture I would still fly through the
confirmation process if the Democrats
want a war on women like let's go yes
woman a central cab let me get this
straight you're using her gender to
defend her where did you get that idea
from American it was negative in other
words I can think I can start that wait
when you're attacking Hillary you're
saying no one I'm playing the own gender
card that you've played gender time
gender card yeah what she's the toughest
woman that's ever served okay if it's
Hillary she was out there overseeing an
interrogation
and you guys think she's too tough on
terrorists let's have that fight have
fun later has it how about tough on who
we are as Americans we're not going to
torture people at that let's just go
torture P hi come on